[Music]
alright let's kick it off no you wait me
you know everyone so a couple weeks ago
we made some III predictions but we
wanted what we wanted to see we are now
like right in the thick of it we're
writing in the war room a bunch of us at
the scene appointments who talk to a lot
of devs Peter what's been big control
easily without a doubt
the oldest house is a shifting place
I've played a lot of remedy games over
the years I've laid them all for
different reasons this one seems to
combine the things that I loved like an
Alan Wake and the combat from quantum
break which is really good and probably
the only thing that game I really likes
basically remedy is chasing the things
that they want to make regardless of if
it makes sense to a mainstream audience
they're basically like we're just
trusting that the people who really care
about new and exciting things are going
to get into us into this the way we are
and that shows and I wish people could
have seen what I saw behind closed doors
and you just kind of a bit breathless
and just talked about it and just you
were using your body a lot to explain
things which I was super into like this
is this is good I think you know so many
of the things that excited a lot of
people here and me to a degree where
sequels or games we'd already known
about this was such an unknown quantity
in the trailer that we saw in Sony's
presentation was good but I had no idea
what I was getting myself in for and
talking to Sam like after the fact
completely just convinced me that they
know what they're doing even though it's
really hard to understand and explain
and it's a third-person action game sure
but it's also a lot more than that it's
like if David Lynch was in the producers
chair telling them how to design the
world and how to keep things from the
players that they were always guessing
and never really sure about what it was
and part of their desire is that they
want people to be online positing
theories and discussing like what is
this about what's the cause how did it
happen I asked like at the end of the
game will players automatically get it
and he was like they should but they but
they might not and that's that's really
intriguing to me yeah I mean like
quantum break was a game that kind of
felt like remedy was framed so and this
this is from what I've seen Oh from what
you've told me it feels a lot like the
remedy of
he describes that he described their
creativity as a pendulum right they have
to go and do the expected thing once in
a while and then they can come back and
do the thing that is just not about
selling multi-million you know or
millions of copies for a platform holder
aka Microsoft now that the vessel is
really really weird I can really
whatever they want it to be instead of
what Microsoft or another company is
telling them it should be that is super
exciting I I want this I just go outside
I don't want to say so I have a phone
because I know everyone's gonna say
saipan you know we all have that
discussion about cyberpunk doesn't say
the same thing and leaves everyone to
YouTube I'm gonna I'm gonna say goes
FEMA
we'd seen nothing of it so far and based
on just what I saw like visually for
example like I really really was
impressed with what that game is doing
like and how it presents that kind of
world around you it looks super dense
and super colorful it's channeling what
I love about sucker punch as a studio in
a lot of different ways so like they're
kind of building on that and presenting
in a different way through a different
lens by using this kind of like samurai
or a thing like you know having him just
that leaping in onto things like this is
slow like it's got a grappling hook for
example and they're taking it really
seriously cuz I also talked to Chris
Zimmerman during the behind-closed-doors
presentation for that where they played
the demo again
he was like vibrating with passion for
having to the chance to make this game
and do all the research that the team
put into really figuring it out like
what was i believe it was 13th century
japan like when the mongols invaded
specifically this island and they went
to that island they went to the beach
for the mongols came like they really
are honing in on their passion for the
era and that that certainly shows like
in the vegetation in the details of the
samurais it's also like we had a really
fun interview them on the Jason Connell
the art creative director on the stage
today and we were talking about how not
only is it kind of cool like confluence
of sucker-punches past but it's also
like a huge tonal shift for that fling
there's like comic book II not just the
story with coal from infamous but also
the combat and the violence there was
very like graphic novel ish whereas this
is graphic like very violent like it the
first time he swings a sword against the
first Mongol is just like you just I
made a point to go down to this age and
watch that interview with these guys and
there were so many things that I really
really liked they talked about how they
want to really crown you in the combat
and they did that through like the
visual element
like yeah you're like gonna be in a
place where there's loads of fallen
leaves those things gonna kick up if you
go through mud it's gonna splash up and
it's not really attracted to and
footprints and stuff yeah and then
you'll be covered in mud until it rains
or something it's just loads of really
cool small detail yeah and that's the
kind of thing that like it everyone's
gonna probably see you're saying I've
got like a while the graphics are great
but it just speaks to how much they want
you to be rooted into the world and they
want you to be rooted into the world
because they know they're building a
super authentic really interesting plate
it's the artistry that they're trying to
to really you know give it his best life
yeah and like what you're saying would
remedy like this is a team also
channeling its passions like the
interview said they talked about how
they bring like the cinematic flair to
it and one of the one of things that
they described was you know the way kind
of like the final battle you see in the
trailer in the red field that kind of
stuff they already won
the wafer since that it's like okay
these guys are doing cinematic flair as
well had that exactly a little bit the
other thing that I really enjoyed though
they were talking about there is like
they they haven't they decided to make
it so you can't understand what the
Mongols are saying like they have no
subtitles right now right and that's
something they're still he had made like
we're not sure how we're gonna you know
I was turned off at first on the
PlayStation demo because they were
speaking English the Japanese characters
but the Mongols weren't it just felt
like that's really in Congress they said
that was just for the presentation right
there is a Japanese option they actually
had dialogue coaches on to tell the
Japanese voice actor yes you're speaking
Japanese but we need you to speak
colloquial Japanese for the era that we
need to tailor your voice to be invited
from a gameplay perspective it's got
that thing that I wanted from it likes a
samurai slowly becoming a ninja kind of
element to it it's got the stuff it's
got like the brutality of both swordplay
and also self like you had that you know
the battle against the group of Mongols
where I seemed like you were very
measured combat you go into account of
state and then you quickly count and
then you're fighting against people and
and then you're in the rafters later I
dropped down do kind of like slow-mo
kills between people that was going
through the wall yeah
[Music]
we rent okay
rezian will to remake I'm going tomorrow
if it watched a lot of gameplay I like
the idea that it's actually kind of grim
now there was always that weird campy
horror to the second original resonable
too but I liked that it actually seems
kind of yeah pretty spooky now I like it
a lot under fun to play that Ken
we watched the the demo and there's
someone who's just getting torn in half
and he actually is like shrieking like
please help me but then also Claire it
as opposed to people who played the
first game will know that there was an
a/b scenario with Leon and Claire now
Claire just has her own campaign which
is awesome and it's also some people are
explaining the comment to me describing
as resi before if you could move while
shooting yeah so when people said you
can move while shooting I wasn't
immediately concerned I was just
thinking I hope it's better than
resonable six combat which I don't wanna
kick it while it's down but it just did
not feel responsive whereas Gray's lay
before was so great about shooting some
in the leg they would not get knocked
down but this seems like it's that plus
they're adding this you can kind of take
a snapshot all of a sudden if like a
liquors jumping at you but if you want
to aim you have to like hold it still
for a few more seconds like someone from
the Giant Bomb was saying that he was
actually waiting like five seconds to
line up a shot correctly it reminds me
it reminds me of the shotgun blind fire
from Gears of War wait does it I guess
just an instant and it feeds into the
survival horror in a really interesting
way like obviously they haven't told me
about its thinking about it like the
thing that happens is when it's a zombie
gets a jump on you in most pressing emo
games the only thing you can do is
either go or like hit the water and run
button and this if you like panic and
automatically shoot you're kind of
making a decision there like you're
taking a risk with like if you don't
keep control you may have just wasted a
bullet
they were also describing that I like
what you said about it feeding into the
survival Horrors but I think it really
does feeding the horror because the devs
are saying the time it takes to aim the
elongated like four to five second day
anytime it's gonna make that bullet all
the much more like you're gonna
anticipate it all the much more grimly
it's gonna be oh [ __ ] I really hope this
hits it's this zombie or else I'm just
like screwed I love that yeah I'm so
excited and like I hope it does well
because it means that maybe we'll get
resident evil 3 treatment doing the same
thing I love Resident Evil freeze my
favorite one of the PlayStation era my
face is one era it'd be very interesting
to see them try to revive that game and
they could feel yeah I mean like we had
a really good talk about res knee well
you have to ruin the authenticity by
saying that 3 is your favorite I think
nemesis is one of the best things in
resume you confirm yeah he's cool but ok
cool Lucy what's your favor of the show
am i good in 2077 they voted my City the
worst place to live in America
main issues sky high rate of violence
and more people living below the poverty
line than anywhere else
so I just came out at the demo just ten
minutes before we started to shoot this
and Peter you asked me how it was at
Oscar was like asking for details and I
just I saw fifty minutes
and when we had them on the stage
yesterday I had no idea what we were
talking about because they didn't show
us any gameplay that microsoft press
conference or anything they just kind of
show the trailer and then Kyle Riley was
like oh I could talk about gameplay and
he just like he just went like before
you even saw shooting he said oh it's
first-person everyone what so I could
see that in action and it's just it's
kind of overwhelming you in a really
really good way so the thing that does
is like it doesn't talk down to you when
it introduces you into the world like
you create your character you give
yourself a backstory and then you kind
of in and you obviously they must have
skipped a few bits but they give you
just like in our context enough context
you kind of understand like what a
Ripper doc is who's gonna augment you
but it's not like a video game II I'm
gonna upgrade my staff this way it just
feels way more than that it feels like a
way more involved process because you
have the doctor they're actually walking
you through like talking you through
what he's doing was like a pebble in
front of your face perhaps what yeah I
think I look and you have to like
actually your arm down to get the
upgrade on your hand and you kind of
have that whole process and it just it's
not just like that but you know they've
thought about the little details but
then you go into its
like the peach trees from dret right
it's like this whole big apartment
complex but it's it's it's only me like
a miracle it's like a mini no they
literally call them a mega building like
it's a fully realized world that you
just happen to be a badass in and doing
it the hosts have created for you to do
these but yeah unlike it does nothing
like the quests you are a badass in this
but it's not like you're the badass
you're not V hero the very beginning you
despite the fact that you go around and
you're basically a mercenary and you're
doing with these jobs and you think
you'd be the badass and then this is
other mercenary who gives you a job and
you're like oh my god he's noticed me
and like he's giving me work to do and
now I'm finally gonna make it so the
when we were talking and they were
saying like oh it's it's a role-playing
game first in combat second so I was
kind of interested to see how that
balance but then they showed a couple of
combat scenarios and it's like man like
the slow-mo stuff you have at one point
they were shooting a gun and it you
could ricochet bullets off again reticle
for that matter like they effectively
remember steamworld dig I think you so
stay well Heights where you can bounce
that it's just that in a 3d world like
it's a red like set line of arrows yeah
well I just read you're gonna miss but
then once it will it will hit someone
else show it as blue and start shooting
I think like powers and stuff like a
dodge like a small distance dodge that I
can let you go back
double jam you also have these cool of
equipment is by Montana
plate called is something you're not
lying mister the larger this day it was
a lot yeah come down this it's like two
blades on it and you can double jump
onto the wall and like sticking down
what the statue that they're giving out
it's the girl from the very first yeah
like Paco along walls and then decide
I'm gonna stick like my blades into the
wall hair kind of like hang people from
a distance well speaking of hacking I
also to go back to what you said about
like you're not the be badass you can
hack people they can hack you as well
yeah so there's one point part when
enemy hacks into your braided list it's
a lie-detector test and in the dialogue
options if you do choose to lie he'll
know yeah so like you'll say like did
you come alone and you'll say like yeah
I came alone but you know during because
you came there with your friend Jackie
you'd be like now he's lying and then
his handle or whatever will say like
send out this drone and I forgot the
drone was sent out until the end of the
50 minute demo like 20 minutes later
when the drone came back yeah the thing
about the world is so so dense and like
the mechanics are dense and every part
of it feels like it's really really
stuff like I'm interested in seeing
whether they can replicate that across
all the regions that they have they say
they're like six different well yeah
areas but it's not just like the small
of the city everything's vertical so
it's like
the thing that I don't really think we
yeah videogames it's like you go into a
building you assume that would be the
ground floor level they'll be like the
first or second floor maybe and usually
the way things work is like the boss
will be at the top so it's work you do
the levels in internet right this it
just seems like there is so much more
going on every level and like to call
back to the Judge Dredd thing it just
feels like yeah it's entire cities
within one building and it's
the best thing is and no loading screens
they like and they said it and they said
it as they were going from like the the
building block and then into an elevator
and it came down onto like street level
motorway and then down into like a like
an alleyway area at the bottom and never
like it was a transparent elevator doors
yeah you see through the window as
you're coming down here the mega
building's Lobby a very it is like it's
it was important I went in ground like I
don't want to get caught up in the hype
yeah and I left to go and I understand
the hype like I get it
this is this is what
[Music]
so pretty ready three yeah stealing
cyberpunk thanks for sailing ghosts
Tsushima you're very welcome Mike thanks
Leela Norrell come on alright I don't
really have anything to do
you